tortillas are here
good morning baby
we provide food assistance for back of
the house restaurant workers
it's a controlled orchestrated chaos
without back of the house workers our
food industry collapses
it's a pleasure feeding those of pet us
for use because they're hungry
Como
Rapides
perfecto
is foreign
Para
[Music]
I found it was without you during the
pandemic I was actually talking to some
of my fellow restaurant owners and
people in the industry and they told me
about these two amazing guys that were
raising money to feed the back of the
house
being at a restaurant or bar we're all
familiar with the hosts the maitre d the
nice server that comes and tells you
what they have available that evening
but what about the back of the house the
people you don't see just everyone that
is cooking our meals washing our dishes
taking out the trash they're the most
essential and so many are undocumented
immigrants
[Music]
the food industry would not exist
without immigrant back of house workers
in the height of the pandemic I was so
frustrated by how our industry was being
treated
when they were shutting down these
workers and unemploying them there was a
ton that never would get those stimulus
checks
even though every week they get taxed on
that paycheck they're not getting any of
the benefits of citizens just because
you know they're not documented to label
them essential when they rightfully are
and not give them any type of support
what are we talking about here that's
just unjust
[Music]
so this is how it all goes down every
Tuesday our families line up
our volunteers they help us
in the boxes we get some Dairy fruits
and veggies some potatoes and then pasta
tortillas chorizo
know us without you
is a non-profit providing resources
ultimately for folks that don't qualify
for any type of government assistance
government Aid
foreign
how you doing
is
la
yeah Marina
bye okay exactly
you're a good man brother
is Jose Ventura is
an opportunity
foreign
foreign
[Music]
and I we know each other through
bartending and we started hanging out
after work drinks getting to know each
other a bit more friendship blossomed
right it makes it sound like we're
dating I know right
so we worked at everything we spoke for
a couple years and then while we're
still working there we started our own
hospitality company and then the
pandemic struck
so we just loaded up our 12 year old
truck with like four hours worth of
groceries out of our own pocket and we
had 10 families that week that we knew
personally and by the end of the next
week it'd become 30 families and then
two weeks later it's 120 because double
tripled you know people were talking to
their brother-in-laws and their
neighbors and their co-workers and staff
they needed help
we have a report with every single
family she needs you guys to be as good
as possible especially you because
you're the oldest we know everyone from
first and last name basis their kids as
well they make tamales for us they
invite us over at their home because we
take the time individually to check in
with everyone
I have a stack of needs now everything
from a job opportunity extra produce CBD
oil for muscle pains because they don't
have health insurance so that's what I'm
doing right now being a little
hummingbird Little Flower to flower
don't mind me
there's this emotional trust that
families are able to confide in Damien
[Music]
you know at our height we're at 1600 now
we're at 600 families because of funding
it's heartbreaking
we're not the government
we're not government funded
we didn't go to school for a social or
Civil Justice degree we're [ __ ]
bartenders man
people that just we just want to help
my
baby is Brandon
Japanese
song
some cases
okay if we
generally
important
[Laughter]
que noise
it gives us a little extra energy it
gives us extra heart and will to to keep
this going
[Music]
[Applause]
right now
Mercedes is a special human
um she not only is an advocate for
Street vendors she cooks for us every
week when she gets the ingredients that
we provide her and her family she
returns the favor today we have
some beautiful pasta with a bit of
cheese and butter just like Grandma
likes to make it
Sanchez
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
to help her employees all throughout the
pandemic
through wages housing jobs food
assistance and just being an advocate
for them is invaluable I've been
fighting the local city officials to
really raise awareness on what their
restrictions and shutdowns were doing to
people like low-income restaurant
workers so when I found Damon othon I
knew that with our celebrity clientele
that we had at Casa Vega that I could
raise money for them I called them up
and said I want to do a taco collab with
my friend Pete Wentz and of course when
I told Pete what it was for he was like
I talked to the band and we want to make
it a Fallout Boy Taco when fundraisers
happen and people see like Fall Out Boy
Casa Vega
she raised you know thousands and
thousand dollars for us
[Music]
night Taco so we're gonna add some pico
de gallo right in there
and then make it really late night we're
gonna add Doritos
and when I made this with Pete we tried
it with french fries we tried it with
Doritos we tried it with Cheetos
and Doritos was the winner to finish it
we used a little bit of cilantro Ranch
Crema
and the base of this is a chicken so
it's just our crispy chicken taco that
we've modified for this like you know
you've just gone to a Fallout Boy
concert and now you're eating these
yummy tacos
[Music]
I'm really good friends with Dave Grohl
and he saw what was going on it's like
well I want a taco and the Foo Fighters
came in
um and just they went crazy we did a
smoked brisket Taco with some pickled
red onions and cilantro and Cotija
cheese
[Music]
my father started Casa Vega in 1956 to
put his immigrant family back to work I
think that that sometimes what people
lose sight of is that the American dream
is when people immigrate they come
across the border their family does
better and thrives over generations and
that's exactly what our family has done
and we always want to remember our roots
and that is why that it caused like no
us without you resonates so much to me
and would make my dad so proud because
the main thing that he always touted was
that he would do anything for his family
and that's what these workers are here
doing when they come and apply for a job
regardless of their legal status they're
simply trying to feed their family
[Music]
just because we can't see the back of
the house workers doesn't mean that they
don't exist
people ask us all the time what do I do
how can I just go meet the person that
you dump bus Tubs on every night just
ask him or her if they're okay and if
they're not [ __ ] do something about
it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]